happy hallows eve reject nation we're
gonna watch today from spider warren
spiderman no way home toby mcguire and
andrew garfield suits descriptions leaks
or something along those lines guys it
was warren's birthday yesterday so make
sure to wish him a happy flipping
birthday and also i'm here they're
supposed to have a morbius trailer i
believe actually it's on tuesday
subscribe and click that notification
bell you know if i'm interaction for
morbius is out yay just what the fans
want that trailer first instead of the
second shredder for spider-man oh and we
did five videos in a row that we're not
spider-man from warren so
you know gotta make up we earned this
we're this one don't judge we just
shuffle in other stuff just so we can be
like oh now we can just say we didn't do
cosmic wonder you know we like there's
nothing we can do
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things that's awesome see
you and today i have a pretty cool new
jack-o-lantern
video for you because i don't normally
post on sundays which is going to be
halloween i'm going to talk about it
today we have a description of what
andrew garfield's and toby mcguire's
costumes are going to look like along
with the green goblins costume in
spider-man no way home also a tiny
description of the black and gold suit
that tom holland will be wearing at one
point in time in the movie so this is a
verified description coming from reddit
the mods have seen the photos but cannot
post them but the leak is confirmed to
be verified and like i said the
descriptions of the full costumes worn
by toby maguire andrew garfield and
willem dafoe and spiderman no way home
we're gonna start with toby's it says
toby's costume is basically the same as
it was in the original trilogy yes sir
as well as hanging next to tom and
andrew's suit the colors look a bit more
vibrant but it could just be the
lighting i'm personally okay with this
because i actually do really enjoy the
look of the sam raimi toby maguire
spiderman suit and if you're going to
bring him back i kind of want him to
look exactly the same yeah the face
obviously look a bit older because some
time has passed and obviously tobey
maguire's gotten older but i would
really like the suit to actually be the
same to be the same spider-man per se
that we saw from the other universe i
feel like it has to be the same for
everyone yes everyone's has to be it
wouldn't be as impactful if they were
just alternate versions who look like
yeah man it's not like when you did the
power rangers show and then you got the
movie
and then they updated it that's my
comparison today yeah it's one to one
it's a one-to-one comparison yeah man if
you're doing this nostalgia of bringing
them back from the past keep it the same
even if it's just pretty much the same
that's how you get the cheers and that's
how you get the feels all right
but if you know it's all stark checked
out and nano taken out i guess i'll get
on board toby's got star trek andrew's
got start tech they're all taking it
back home andrew's costume is basically
the same as it was in the amazing
spider-man 2 as well we were only able
to see it hanging next to the other
suits but we can confirm it matches the
costume in the leaked video of andrew
garfield i think most people have seen
that leaked video by now i've even done
a few videos on it myself after it was
pretty much in the general public for
everybody to see during this leaked
video the costume looked awesome andrew
garfield looked awesome and i'm really
excited to see him back as spider-man
with toby maguire alongside of tom
holland now the green goblin's costume
apparently is not going to look exactly
the same it says green goblin's costume
is the raimi suit with an updated design
it's somewhat damaged and patchy and a
few minor adjustments have been made it
includes add-ons like a comic accurate
tan colored shoulder strap and belt with
a bomb bag some gold colored accessories
on his legs and some scattered purple
accessories like a cloth wrapped around
his arm metallic exoskeleton looking
parts fill in some of the damaged parts
and the thighs the costume is still
almost entirely green it's still very
clearly the raimi suit from 2002 just
with add-ons no mask is being worn in
the image just black goggles like doc ox
and spider-man 2 we also know he'll have
a purple scarf slash hood at some point
thanks to previous leaks you see i'm
more fine with the villains having a bit
of an update because
if the leaks are to be believed which uh
i've heard more stuff outside of just
what you've seen us react to
are you subject to leaks uh
no
kevin feige says no we're not how is
that gonna come to my daughter's
christening i'm sorry so i'm more okay
with the villains having a change due to
the fact that if you're pulling them out
from the moments of when we last saw
them in spider-man 1 and spider-man 2
when they're coming back into the
universe to get their fight game on
they're probably going to update it a
tad bit right because they're going
toe-to-toe with spidey again and whereas
with you know what guy and andrew
garfield some time has passed for them
so they've had time to just you know
take his bill laundry and freshen it up
get it dry clean with that yelp discount
you know you know they got all the means
because they're not like fugitives
assumed to be dead yeah yeah and it's
kind of like doc what we've seen so far
it's a slight update it's not like
massively different but it's slightly
updated yeah well i feel like that's
classic too the hero is kind of
steadfast and then when the villains
reappear they've always got some kind of
upgrade you know yeah
i don't really have guys feel like the
heroes get upgrades too now they also
have a tiny bit of info about tom's
black and gold suit it says also shared
with us were descriptions of an early
version of tom's black and gold suit
with bits of red in it it was a physical
suit and there's a cell phone duct tape
to the chest for some reason now when i
hear a cell phone taped to the chest i
typically think bomb however i don't
think tom holland's spider-man has a
bomb strapped to his chest we're going
to blow up the center survive in gold
suit it's really just spider-man's black
and red suit flipped inside out so why
you would have a cell phone to it i'm
not really sure but it's nice that some
mystery is still left for this movie
that has just an absolutely crazy amount
of leaks going around about it i mean
maybe he had the cell phone attached
just for like a certain scene you know
like this this feels like it's going to
be a big chase movie simultaneously so
maybe whoever he's having to communicate
with via cell phone but he doesn't have
pockets in his spider-man suit so maybe
he just has to like flip it onto his
chest and then run around that way he
can like access it again this spider-man
suit clearly needs a shirt pocket
like this or maybe peter's making more
web videos you know i just wanted to get
like a chest cam that's also a likely
good idea yeah
yeah
logan parker yeah but that's it for what
i'll call today's halloween video a
description of the costumes for toby
mcguire andrew garfield and willem dafoe
super smooth absolutely cannot wait
until we see these on screen and see all
three of these men returning as their
respective characters go ahead and let
me know how excited you are for them to
return in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock hope
everybody has a happy halloween and stay
safe and as always thank you all so much
for watching check your candy i'm gonna
have a great holiday and i'm going as a
[ __ ] oh good
bloodiest lunch
anyway guys i hear we got more beers
trailer next week so keep a lookout for
that subscribe click that bell hit that
like button let's keep a lookout for
that spider-man trailer too last but not
least
scuba steve we saved the best for last
because out of anyone on our patreon
page he's probably the biggest horror
fanatic that we know when i first got to
know scuba he was constantly just
talking about his love for specific
horror films and always wanted us to
talk about horror this has to be your
month i hope that tomorrow you got a
lovely date next to you you cut a hole
at the bottom of a popcorn bucket you
get arrested gets into jail saying
that's not allowed anymore this is 2021.
stop listening to dave chappelle and joe
rogan you can't get away with that then
you're gonna be like but they're just
jokes that dave chappelle and joe rogan
take i don't actually take their life
advice i can separate myself from comedy
versus reality and then go you're still
problematic and then it's gonna just go
off the rails from there or as opposed
to how focused your shoutout was for
today it was like a laser beam it was
good it was scary good trick or treat
some women tomorrow in a way that is
respectable absolutely non-problematic
[Music]
you